la démarche en sciences sociales c'est
une démarche qui est d'abord
scientifique quelle est la démarche
scientifique en règle générale
d'abord on démarre toujours du réel le
réel c'est ce qui nous entoure la
réalité
alors je peux prendre un exemple des
bulles vont former à la surface de l'eau
quand je pose une casserole sur le feu
à partir de cette observation
je vais construire un objet d'étude
donc je vais dire que ce qui m'intéresse
c'est en fait la relation qui lie 10
lots aux bulles et à la chaleur
je vais les finir le fait qu'il y ait
des bulles à la surface de l'eau ou dans
l'eau comme un phénomène que je vais
appeler une punition
et le fait que l'eau très chaude je vais
appeler saab juste sa température on
voit bien que j'ai défini d'un concept
qui n'ont qu'une seule signification
c'est ce qui est important science c'est
que chaque mot est égale à une chose
alors que dans la langue française un
mot peut vouloir dire plusieurs choses
avec ces deux concepts je vais pouvoir
définir une hypothèse qui est en fait
une proposition une explication que je
peux faire de la réalité du réel ici je
vais faire l'hypothèse que la
température de l'eau est la cause de
l'ébullition
armé de cette hypothèse on peut mettre
en place diverses expériences ou
différents expérimentateurs différents
endroits de la surface de la terre
à différents moments là peuvent réaliser
une expérience qui aura les mêmes
résultats et qui sera revue et qu'en
retirant la casserole de la source de
chaleur les bulles disparaissent et
réapparaissent lorsque l'eau a accumulé
suffisamment de chaleur c'est à dire
quand sa température atteint 100 degrés
à partir de cette l'un étant donné que
l'expérience est un succès dont
plusieurs conditions
metz peut conclure que mon hypothèse est
validée que cette observation me permet
de valider cette hypothèse de dire qu'en
effet il y à bien une relation de
causalité entre la température de l'eau
et son émulation j'ai fait une
proposition du réel qui s'avère ici être
vérifié par l'expérience
en sciences sociales la démarche est
plus ou moins similaire
quelques points après
je veux me poser une question de départ
qui va me permettre d'explorer mon sujet
vous n'aviez d'études qui va ensuite
déboucher sur une problématique
dans laquelle je vais construire un
modèle d' analyse qui lui même sera
soumis comme dans la démarche
scientifique à l'observation
j'analyserai mais le résultat et je
tirerai certaines conclusions et si mes
conclusions sont corrects et si j'en ai
encore envie je peux à partir de mes
conclusions
recommencer une nouvelle question la
science sociale comme la science en
général mais c'est un processus qui
n'est jamais fini il ya toujours des
choses à découvrir
alors la question de départ en
particulier mais ça me permettre
d'amorcer la recherche de la commencer
elle doit d'être clair faisable et
pertinente cette question de départ et
en plus je dois faire très attention à
ne pas émettre des jugements de valeur
il est très important aussi de formuler
ses propres représentations l'aimé
représentation c'est ce que je pense
c'est mes idées par rapport au réel au
monde qui m'entoure moi j'ai des idées
là mes idées parfois sont en décalage
avec les idées des autres ce sont des
représentations
je peux utiliser la philosophie ou
prendre un petit peu la position d'un
idiot un qui demande toujours pourquoi
pourquoi si pourquoi là afin de
justement amorcé cette recherche c'était
une position qu'on peut prendre
alors ici pour illustrer les différentes
étapes je vais prendre par exemple cas
de la réussite scolaire mais
représentation en réussite scolaire
pourrait être alors je ne dis pas
qu'elles se sont celles là mais pour
était par exemple que
réussi celui qui travaille celui qui
dort sur ses cours celui qui ne fait
rien ne réussit pas voilà par exemple ma
représentation par rapport à cet objet
d'art
avec cette question ben voila je peux en
tout cas avec cette question de départ
qu'elles sont là quels sont les les
influences les choses qui influence la
réussite scolaire mais je pars à la
recherche d'informations alors je peux
lire plusieurs ouvrages des ouvrages de
vulgarisation c'est par exemple une
revue en sciences sociales comme
sciences humaines la revue sciences
humaines qui permet dans des mots plus
ou moins simples d'explorer comme ça
différents sujets et différents objets
d'étude
ça peut être bien sûr la presse
quotidienne parfois il ya des articles
un peu plus poussé mais ça peut être
aussi des entretiens exploratoires je
vais voir des gens sur le terrain et je
leur pose des questions par exemple ici
je peux poser des questions à des
enseignes retient pour vous quels sont
les éléments importants qui permettent
un élève de réussir et l'enseignant bas
va me donner plusieurs éléments de
réponses qui vont aiguiller leur
recherche
c'est aussi le moment cette exploration
où je peux confronté ce que je pense
mais représentation à celle des autres
ou à ce que je peux lire dans
différentes sources ici je vous avais
dit que pour moi le travail
était la cause de la réussite ou de
l'échec scolaire de l'échec scolaire je
peux très bien à lire des articles qui
me disent que des élèves qui travaillent
beaucoup rate voilà mes représentations
sont dit les directement ici battue en
brèche
alors voyez ici les changes est vraiment
très important le fait de d'échanger
avec les autres va permettre justement
d'air d'avancé sur ses représentations
et explorer un petit peu mieux cet objet
d'étude
pendant cette phase il faut bien sûr
décoder les discours il faut pas croire
noir sur blanc ce que ce qu'on lit ou ce
que les gens disent il faut essayer de
lire entre les lignes c'est pas facile
une fois que je considère que j'ai
suffisamment explorées mon objet d'étude
je vais un peu le définir plus
précisément parce que la réussite
scolaire je peux très bien l'analyser
d'un certain point de vue plutôt que
d'un autre par exemple je peux
investiguer au point de vue de la de
l'addiction est ce que l'addiction mois
à certaines substances on parle souvent
des gens qui fument du cannabis est-ce
que l'addiction au cannabis joue sur la
réussite scolaire voilà ça c'est une
position je pourrais prendre dans ma
recherche une problématique qui pourrait
m'intéresser mais qui est une
problématique
qui est plutôt sanitaire par exemple
alors si je vais prendre une
problématique plus sociale je ne me
retiens est ce que les enfants les
élèves qui viennent d'un milieu scolaire
défavorisés qui sont dosés dans les
indes des instituts scolaire ou dans des
écoles qui sont dans des milieux dans
les quartiers où il ya un indice
socio-économique que élevé est ce que
ces élèves là réussissent mieux ou moins
bien que des élèves qui sont bas dans
une école plus privilégiés comme par
exemple derrière quoi voilà ça c'est le
genre de question qu'on pourrait
directement se poser c'est aussi une
problématique
il existe une multitude de
problématiques d'où l'intérêt de bien
définir
je choisis ma problématique une fois
j'ai bien choisi ma problématique je
définis les concepts importants alors
les concepts importants c'est comme par
exemple ici avec ma casseroles qui vous
sur la cuisinière j'ai défini ce qu est
l ébullition j'ai défini ce qu'était la
température c'est important pour avancer
ici voilà dans la problématique en
sciences sociales là je vais définir les
concepts importants que je l'utilisé
c'est vraiment le moment où je me décide
de où je vis
une fois que j'ai bien défini cette
problématique je vais pouvoir construire
mon modèle d' analyse la en utilisant
des hypothèses comme dans la démarche
scientifique
alors je peux m ça c'est plus tard en
sixième enfin vous ferez sans doute ça c
est mettre en relation plusieurs
hypothèses et là on obtient vraiment un
modèle d' analyse
alors on a parlé de concepts la réussite
scolaire voilà la réussite scolaire
c'est un concept mais bon je me baladais
je peux me balader dans beaucoup
d'écoles je ne verrai jamais la réussite
scolaire en tant que tel ce sont des
concepts abstraits et donc je dois un
petit peu leur donner du corps leur
donner quelque chose de tangible quelque
chose qu'on sait mesurer la réussite
scolaire quelque chose de tangible de la
colère ça peut être les notes des élèves
ou alors le fait d'avoir un diplôme ou
alors on peut aussi considérer que la
réussite scolaire c'est l'apprentissage
d'un élève mais là c'est aussi quelque
chose qui est plus difficile à mesurer
les notes le diplôme sont des
indicateurs précis de la réussite
scolaire donc je dois penser aussi à ça
dans le cas ici d'une recherche sur la
réussite scolaire je peux être père
l'hypothèse que l'orientation scolaire
va avoir une incidence sur la réussite
un élève bien orienté qui est contente
seule option réussira mieux qu'un élève
colo à qui on oblige le voilà tu feras
ça tu feras j'éteins la times at il a
envie de le la times robert mattes
baisse que les lettres ici lieu qu'un
heller qui a vraiment vite faire
l'atteindre
alors cette hypothèse je vais je pas en
rester là je vais aller sur le terrain
pour l'observer je peux faire une
observation à partir d'un questionnaire
questionnaire et je demande à 50 100 150
personnes de 10 répondre je peux faire
aussi des entretiens je rencontre des
personnes je leur pose des questions
je peux aussi aller directement sur le
terrain alors dans la réussite scolaire
c'est plus difficile mais je peux très
bien faire sur les inégalités scolaires
je paie fins de recherche là dessus et
aller en classe de voir est ce pire des
inégalités scolaires dans les plats
c'est ce que certains élèves sont
défavorisés par le des enseignants par
exemple par rapport à d'autres est ce
que certains élèves manquent de matériel
par rapport à d'autres voilà ça c'est
une observation je pourrais me rendre
dans les classes et un petit peu
observer comment ça se passe mais ça
peut être aussi une observation
statistiques donc c'est des chiffres par
exemple ici dans la réussite scolaire je
peux prendre les statistiques de voir
combien d'élèves ont obtenu css
l'année dernière directement jeu
l'indicateur et j'ai fait une
observation statisme ça peut être aussi
recherché dans des documents évidemment
alors je dois toujours définir un plan
d'observation je me dis pas tiens je
vais aller observer si je dois observer
la dont je fais qu'un protocole c'est à
dire le fait vraiment une feuille avec
les différentes étapes de mon
observation qu'est-ce que je dois
observer observer comment je vais
l'observer quand je vais l'observer où
est ce que je veux
et puis je réalise bien sûr nos
observations voilà en exemple à
l'entretien ou alors l'utilisation de
sources statistiques
bien sûr j'analyse les résultats j'ai
obtenu je dois préparer les résultats
pour mon analyse souvent je jean cocteau
dans un tableau excel j'essaye de
numériser l'information en tout cas de
la rendre la plus synthétique possible
pour pouvoir la travailler parce que si
j'ai fait des entretiens que j'ai posé
des questions des gens les gens m'ont
raconté leur vie et puis qu'est-ce que
je suis avec tout ça il faudra
finalement je repère certains mots que
chacun utilise pour pouvoir un petit peu
rationaliser tout ça et pour pouvoir
travailler ce matériel que j'ai obtenus
par l'observation
voilà je mesure les indicateurs que
j'avais retenu et je compare les
résultats attendus
et puis ici à des gros écart entre ce
que je mate ce à quoi je m'attendais est
ce que j'observe je me pose des
questions et là ça peut être l'objet
d'une nouvelle recherche
ici dans le cas de la réussite scolaire
si je dis ben voilà
l'orientation a une influence sur la
réussite scolaire maintenant si je
constate que beaucoup d'élèves qui se
déclare pas être à l'aise dans leurs
options réussisse la voilà par rapport à
ce que je m'attendais par rapport à
l'hypothèse que j'avais formulée bah
tiens il ya un écart donc là je vais
essayé de l'expliquer aussi et on
utilise bien sûr souvent excellent il ya
d'autres logiciels mais en secondaire en
astérix m
et puis je formule mes conclusions je
rappelle tout ma démarche depuis le
début
je présente les connaissances que j'ai
produites donc en gros est ce que mon
hypothèse ou réfuter ou pas
et plus je trace les perspectives des
recherches futures qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait faire pour améliorer
cette chaire 6 quels sont les éléments
que j'ai dû laisser de côté qu'est-ce
qui pourrait travailler voilà ça c'est
des choses qu'on peut mettre dans sa
conclusion et puis je définis les
limites de la recherche je dis voilà par
exemple mon échantillon j'ai interrogé
dix personnes mais c'est ça reste
anecdotique c'est pas assez important
que pour établir une vérité scientifique
il faudrait peut-être avoir un
échantillon de où tant de personnes
voilà aussi des éléments qui peuvent
être intéressants donc là c'est vraiment
une phase où je me pose des questions et
bien justement parlant question si vous
en avez venez avec vos prochains cours
on y répondra et puis on continuera
notre petit bonhomme de chemin en
sciences sociales à bientôt